[Musique]
bonjour alors je m'appelle mathien ce
chariot et 40 devant suis artisan
manises et
[Musique]
j'ai créé l'entreprise basilou qui est
une menuiserie artisanale où je crée
fabrique et
réaliste des meubles intelligent on va
dire qu'ils prennent pas de passes qui
se replie plus tôt en bois de tamarin
puisqu'on est à la réunion et aussi du
meuble sur mesure en fonction des
besoins et des demandes des clients
je travaille beaucoup le bois massif qui
revient à la mode actuellement avec un
mélange aussi le matériau avec du métal
et bois après du bambou par exemple si
les matériaux assez nouveau jeu concours
la catégorie innovation car j'ai créé
inventé ce bureau d'écolier en fête qui
rappelle les pupitres longtemps qu'ils
se replient intégralement qui prend pas
de place tout simplement et qui est
destiné aux enfants de 2 à 9 ans par la
petite taille et pour les 9 ans et plus
pour les grands modèles à vendre
l'entreprise j'étais demandeur d'emploi
je suis parti donc deux en métropole où
je me suis fait formé à l'afp a donc me
divier d'agencement ensuite j'ai
travaillé en intérim soit les chantiers
de l'atlantique vers les paquebots où
ils font des ponts de bateaux antiques
mais j'avais vraiment envie de
monter mon entreprise non je me suis
auto financé à 100 % c'est que du
bonheur d'être chef d'entreprise fait
les choix qu'on veut décide du jour
n'est pas très très vite recevoir les
clients acheter les matériaux
transformés livres et laisser ce qui est
passionnant aussi une forte augmentation
de l'activité par rapport au
prévisionnel que j'avais fixé au départ
je suis largement dessus
pourquoi pas embaucher une deuxième
personne dès l'année prochaine alors je
vais gagner le challenge des créateurs
parce que j'ai inventé 1,9 le pratique
beau intelligent qui se replient et qui
répond à une forte demande des des
clients tout simplement bonjour je
m'appelle mic avec larry j'ai 29 ans et
je suis le gérant de la sarl show punch
la société chopinot chez une société de
lavage automobile principalement
écologique on utilise des machines
vapeur et des produits qui sont
respectueux de l'environnement donc nous
avons versa il ya maintenant une dizaine
de mois et nous sommes sur le parking du
centre commercial à jumbo
donc nous avons décidé de concourir dans
la catégorie innovation tout simplement
car ce skipper de carwash n'existait pas
actuellement sur les centres commerciaux
qui était présent sur la réunion et nous
avons décidé d'innover en créant ce
nouveau concept est proposée aux
utilisateurs du centre de pouvoir
maintenant faire nettoyer leurs
véhicules en même temps qu'ils vont
faire leurs courses ou qu'il se promène
dans la galerie avant de créer cette
société j'ai donc été militaire pendant
huit ans pour la création de cette
activité nous avons été aidés par le
département par le biais du tage et
surtout par réunion entreprendre et le
crédit agricole qui sont les deux
organismes qui nous ont principalement
financier avant tant que militaire est
vrai que je me déplaçais beaucoup je
t'ai pas très souvent à la maison c'est
pour ça que j'ai décidé de changer
d'activité est de pouvoir créer une
société avec un emploi qui serait plus
sédentaires où je pourrais vraiment
m'occuper de toute ma famille maintenant
je peux au moins rester proche de ce que
j'aime et me consacrer pleinement à mon
métier
donc nous allons remporter ce concours
car cette société est vraiment un
nouveau concept sur la réunion avant ça
n'existait pas il n'avait aucun centres
commerciaux qui était doté donc de
centre de nettoyage et surtout nous
utilisons des produits qui sont français
on utilise de la vapeur d'eau avec
laquelle on économise énormément d'eau
on est sur une consommation entre 5 et
10 litres d'eau maximum par véhicule et
surtout remporter tout ça nous
permettrait de pouvoir développer notre
société d'agrandir notre surface de
nettoyage et par la suite surtout de
pouvoir embaucher un salarié
[Musique]